now your chance to be a leader and step
up and having more courage how you
respond to a negative comment can also
be an inspiration so tomorrow you're
starting a new pattern it's a new you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you got how can I help about
entrepreneurship yeah why did I want to
be an entrepreneur regret like whatever
whatever has held you back from writing
your songs for 15 years or long has been
I would imagine myself at a hundred and
I you never wrote your song what happend
like why didn't you write your song you
still have a lot of time left but you
didn't never wrote the song and I don't
make that so painful because whatever
you're afraid whatever the reason is
that you didn't do it you've wanted to
do it forever and now you're a hundred
and it's over and you can't do it and
then I use that to push me forward I
look at the other side because we only
focus typically on the fear that's in
front of us it's looking at the fear for
life behind it because you're not happy
that you haven't been the song in 15
years it's just been little bits cuz on
a daily you don't feel the unhappiness
but then all of a sudden you look back
and like holy cow it's been 10 years and
I'm still in the same spot so now use
that not to say that I suck and like I
can never do this is that well that
sucked but I want to be better because I
don't want to die without having to get
getting my music out there so I use that
mindset shift we get lots and I get a
feedback the thing is like that whatever
the thing is that you're afraid of
getting feedback on that's the story the
right whatever story that's in your head
that you're worried that somebody your
colleague might see it that's the one
that you need to be writing you're not
gonna I mean you're not gonna get fired
because you're a vet but if you do then
you don't want to be there anyway right
if this is your story and somebody and
your boss comes in and says I hate this
thing about you you're fired you don't
want to be there anyway right so that
will actually make your content better
exposing the real hardships that your
boss might read or your colleagues might
read and then having the real strength
to stand up to it and say hi this is me
this is me and I get it and you may not
understand that that's okay but this is
me so one is
just having a courage to do it to write
that piece of content when you get the
negative feedback one understand that if
someone is leaving you a negative
comment that's the highlight of the day
how crappy your life do they have to
have that coming to your LinkedIn and
leave it a negative comment gets them
excited right so just just and that
removes the sting because I'll get I'll
get all I talk about is believe it's
only positive right if I did a top 10
stupidest things that this person said
or did my channel probably would be
bigger because we'd rather run away from
a life that we don't like then actually
build a better one
so watching how other people suck we
love escapism instead of education to
build a better life so somebody come in
here your page and leaving your negative
comment if that's their highlight like
how about a life do they have to be
living right now so that removes the
sting if you just if you just say that
it's it'll still sting but then you see
it it's like okay you know what this
person is having a really bad day right
and then what I like is how you respond
to a negative comment can also be an
inspiration for everybody else who's
reading the post so it's now your chance
to be a leader and step up and have even
more courage we've got a negative
comment if it's against me orphans
against somebody that were profiling
we'll look at how can I use this as an
opportunity to not change this person's
mind but to approach it in a way that
would inspire everybody else who's
reading the comments maybe you want to
have compassion maybe you want to fight
for your beliefs like there's no right
answer but something that would make you
proud what would the best version of you
respond to that negative comment not in
hopes of changing the person but
inspiring to people who are Whedon
the only the only ones that for me I
will on YouTube will block people from
my channel is if one they're attacking
somebody else so if you come after me
great but you're coming after somebody
else in the community then you're out if
they're like being super racist or
telling someone to kill themselves or
something then I don't want them in my
community but if somebody's coming after
you and saying hey your dog
whose idea is stupid I come on in a
military really dr. Seuss are you
kidding me
all right great I would keep that up and
then respond that responded in a way
because other people are also thinking
too that they're thinking about it and
you're also teaching people how to deal
with haters and criticism like if you
approach it in a loving way instead of
fighting maybe that's the best version
of you like I want to love this person
and you're coaching a loving way instead
of fighting somebody else we'll see how
you're doing that
I say how that's super interesting and
then maybe they approach it in the
loving way with criticism in their life
maybe not an online comment but maybe
it's their mom that's criticizing them
and instead of yelling back and forth
they approach you in a loving way
because they saw what you did on
LinkedIn it's doing a lot of the stuff
we did today
right like well but so having your
morning routine that you do every day
and you wake up when you do that thing
and you remind yourself of what you're
trying to do you remind yourself that I
haven't done I haven't done the thing in
10 years I haven't written in 10 years
like I use that pain to drive me forward
to write to get one page you done even
if it sucks just that that one page is
better than what I've done in the past
10 years right he came in sang a song
and he just wrote it here 15 years have
wanted to is it the greatest song of all
time could he do better of course he
could do better but he started and then
I think in 15 years it's great right
it's um it's momentum remind yourself of
that but I use it as a kick forward not
down so it's not looking at you need a
kick because otherwise you stay where
you are right but most people kick
themselves down and say I suck I haven't
done in 10 years and never gonna do it
I'm always do this I never stick to the
thing about I suck great it's why you
need to build the identity of when I set
a goal I follow through and it starts
with something as simple as your alarm
clock in the morning so whenever you set
a goal like the best thing you can do is
whatever is on your seven-day list
24-hour list like you go off and do it
and you start to rewire and you can now
you can believe you know what okay I
could if I set a goal for 24 hours I
could do it okay I'm starting to think
I'm somebody who can follow through it's
the running at three No
in the morning when I got no energy just
to show myself that I follow through on
goals and the more you do that that
becomes your new identity that I am the
kind of person who sets goals and I
follow through so you you set a goal you
have your calendar is there writing time
in the calendar so when are you writing
the accountant way ok great so tomorrow
morning you wake up and you're right I'm
just doing that when was the last time
you woke up and wrote great but so
tomorrow you're starting a new pattern
it's a new you I would even go home
tonight and write like go right in the
parking lot a paragraph write the
two-percent right in one paragraph is so
much further ahead than nothing and then
you wake up tomorrow you do it again and
then tomorrow you do it again yourself I
don't want to be in this
[Music]
yes I was just looking for guidance
matters the sober now yes you know make
some money but a little bit other
problems in real business certain
business and entrepreneurs are the
hardest things you can ever do in your
life and picking the right partners
people often go off of the wrong things
you off of just the skills I'm gonna
sales and discuss bit of coding and this
has good of money so we should be great
but just like in a relationship because
you're only going off of acre most of
those don't work have any people align
with the values then as well value this
but my partner's they don't problem
that'll show up forever meaning your
business and you need to decide if
they're okay with that or not can you
handle it or not sometimes like yes if
they're gonna steal that about it's too
big of value chasm across something like
this a slow burn your mindset on slow
burn will be there forever and there's
always gonna be it issues with the
company so are you okay increasing that
or not and these are the recognized to
begin with or not this is about as a
difference it's really hard for a
relationship was a succeed and then even
relationship if it was just a mindset or
a knowledge gap you can fix that to
logic well you can't you can't use logic
to convince them I'm gonna values a
difference yeah I got a little burn
well they don't you're not gonna
convince some of they won't convince you
nobody's right it's just you value
different things so is that to mean a
good value for you guys to be able to
cross the biggest hell of a different
relations are gonna work is your ability
to a little all for the other so are
these guys you can see yourself moving
together with through all the ups and
downs of entrepreneurship for the next
ten years so you have so many people
you know the interview and then times we
don't interview them that you're showing
their content yep how do you put that
into a video without stepping on like
you know infringing on like other things
are like content being okay without
getting in trouble right from the
YouTube standpoint and those if it's a
big company
I think NBC ABC fox any of the movie
studios you're not gonna make money from
the video delete or block it or they'll
monetize it so they might just block and
take it down you're not penalized but it
won't be up or they'll let it stay up
and they'll just monetize it if it's
from a smaller creator an individual
then they have the opportunity to strike
your channel and so you need to work
with them so the with the big company is
where we profile like NBC we never use
because NBC will always block it it's
just like company policy but if we do a
CNN clip we're never gonna make money in
that entire video because see anyone
monetize it but we'll still do it
because it's it's good and we want to I
want to spread the message for other
guys like Gary or grant or Tom or those
guys we've relationships with them where
they could strike the channel they could
say hey this is my content you can't use
it but we form relationships with them
so that they want to they see the
benefit now it helps if it's only
positive it's never top ten Gary sucks
although Gary be okay with that but like
other people wouldn't you know top ten
like this person's an idiot and here's
why they probably wouldn't like that and
so that you might get a strike for that
so if you're using smaller channels then
you'd have to work out something with
them so all in the entrepreneur and what
I do there's only a handful of people
who are doing it right there's this
grand thing Gary and Tom and Marie and
Patrick and it's like you know that's it
so you start with one like tony was one
of the first ones you started working
with three years ago three years ago ish
maybe three and a half and then you know
use that to go and get other people and
then you're building a base
full of videos where it was kind of like
car karaoke and it turned out it was
just for fun but then it turned into
something but now I'm not like putting
the content out because I've had a lot
of people saying you can't do that
because you'll get striked or like
what's your experience with music are
they really serious music is a special
beast yeah music is its own crazy animal
we were doing music like productivity
playlist for entrepreneurs that we
stopped because the music industry is
super hardcore if I was you I would I
would try to make deals like if you want
to keep that series going find people
who are doing covers that you like that
you enjoy like whatever song you would
do you love this Beyonce song great like
find someone who did a great cover of it
and say I'd love to feature your song in
my video and then and then do it like
that
it won't be the original but what's up
believe nation we are here in Columbus
doing a tour what have you guys learned
give me some give me some learnings from
today so far immediate action go now
stop playing small let's go let's go to
the other side what do you guys got here
create momentum keep it I love it what
else eat through the judgment who said
that I like it what else - Margene
morning routine one more play big I love
it all right Ruby's empty
how'd it go we're done Columbus some
time is it 10:30 pretty good new changes
for my changes I liked it I added more
Q&A it was good the questions were good
at the end everybody just wanted to
basically take pictures and then take
off positively to the Q&A and then some
people stuck around and accepted helping
it was good like it's all good here's
the thing though we're playing in the
greens like it's great it's really good
it's a it's a great start some amazing
bass and now we're playing with with the
icing and how to make it even better now
there's a bunch of people who helped me
in promoting this Columbus 2 or thank
you I want to show some love roll it
if you want to see what I did in
Pittsburgh on my tour check out the link
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy that session continue to believe
and I'll see you there